build illusion in eagle pass texas with
more bill
neil good afternoon to you late last
week you'll remember texas governor greg
abbott authorized the texas national
guard and texas troopers to not just
detain illegal immigrants but also
return them to the border to the ports
of entry we have just witnessed the
beginning of one of the first instances
of this happening these two buses right
here are texas dps buses they are full
of illegal immigrants right now take a
look at this video we just shot about 15
minutes ago as these buses were loaded
up this was a group of predominantly
single adults as well as family units
about 75 migrants in total here who had
just crossed over illegally into this
private orchard here in eagle pass texas
troopers were here they took custody of
all of them immediately separated them
between single adults as well as family
units and then put them on these buses
what's going to happen now is they're
going to be transported over to the port
of entry here in eagle pass this is a
big change previously when dps would
encounter illegal immigrants they would
just call border patrol and border
patrol would take custody texas governor
greg abbott is fed up with what's
happening down here so he is cutting out
the middle man he is allowing his texas
resources to take these illegal
immigrants and physically return them to
the border to the ports of entry here on
the u.s side of the border and that is
what is happening right now as we speak
why is he doing this take a look at this
video we shot over the weekend here in
eagle pass massive numbers of migrants
continue spilling over the border here
in texas day in and day out you are
looking at video of a single massive
group of approximately 300 that crossed
over on saturday in broad daylight the
scorching temperatures 108 degrees when
we shot this video it's 109 degrees as
i'm speaking to you right now but these
were single adults families coming from
all over the world it happens at night
time as well take a look at this video
we shot last night as we embedded with
texas dps troopers on private ranches in
kenney county looking for illegal
immigrants who were sneaking through the
brush through these private ranches
texas dps troopers tracking footprints
backpacks left under trees within a
matter of moments we find this group of
six illegal immigrants who were hiding
in the brush trying to evade law
enforcement keep inside what you're
looking at here is 15 miles inland from
the u.s mexico border these guys had
already slipped past border patrol and
if it wasn't for these texas troopers
they would have gotten further into the
united states last night we had a chance
to talk with one of the local ranch
owners out there who had a human
smuggler drive through a fence in her
property last night in a stolen car we
asked her what does she think about the
administration's claims that the border
is closed here's what she said oh that's
a joke
i mean they ought to come down here and
and fear for their lives i mean and
they're not staying here
i mean they're coming through my ranch
because they're headed somewhere else
they're not staying in kennedy county
but the borders not closed they're
pouring across every day
and they're destroying our property
and part of what you just heard right
there is the reason why governor greg
abbott says he feels he has to take this
action through an executive order those
two buses have just left they are going
to drop those migrants off at the port
of entry there are still some migrants
left over right here mostly small
children and some parents here some of
the migrants brought this little dog
with them as well as you can see but
they are not going to go with dps dps is
calling border patrol to come take
custody of them because there are little
children in the group so as you can see
fast moving situation here but what
you've just witnessed is one of the
first instances of governor greg
abbott's new executive order being
carried out as state of texas resources
are now rounding up illegal immigrants
personally and dropping them off at the
border at the port of entry on the u.s
side what happens after that we're going
to find out we got a camera coup over
there we'll keep you guys posted we'll
send it back to you in the meantime to
your point bill you've already got the
uh the president mexico saying that this
you know shifting them back to mexico is
immoral
as if you know letting them stay in the
united states is is not
you know he's going to be meeting with
the president on this who seems to share
its concern about texas here where is
this going
well i think a lot of people would like
to be a fly on the wall of that meeting
tomorrow it's going to be probably a
little bit awkward because remember amlo
just stood up president biden
essentially was the summit of the
americas in los angeles recently he
didn't go now they're going to be
meeting tomorrow they got a lot on their
plate to talk about it when it comes to
illegal immigration border security the
amount of drugs pouring across the
border neil all that video you just saw
of those migrants spilling across the
border mexico allows massive numbers of
migrants to just travel through their
country and arrive at their northern
border with the united states and that
is one of governor greg abbott's biggest
frustrations as he feels
amlo the mexicans aren't doing enough to
try to stop some of that migration to
their northern border they feel texas
really needs some help from the mexican
side and they feel they're not getting
that help right now yeah we've shown and
thanks to you video at the video of how
those you know migrants just move
unobstructed through mexico on their way
to our country uh bill thank you very
much for that bill illusion hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now